i'm hitting record right now so you're
ready
awesome okay thank you uh
let me actually figure out what i'm
gonna say um
okay right so thanks so much all of you
for coming back
um let me see if i can share my screen
um so yesterday we we covered
in a slightly scatter gun and fast-paced
and not particularly rigorous way
some connection between ideas in uh
abstract rewriting theory and multi-way
systems and you know possible
formalistic connections to aspects of
quantum mechanics
um and what i want to try to do today is
to convince you that these sort of
slightly hand-wavy suggestions i made
about
you know relationships between
completion procedures and orthogonal
projections and relationships between
collections of rewrite rules and you
know unitary evolution operators those
kinds of things
i i want to try to make those uh sort of
correspondences a bit more precise
uh and hopefully try to convince you
that there is um
there is a sort of a nice geometrical
intuition for what what the multi-wave
evolution graph and what the branchial
graphs actually are
and that sort of corresponds really
rather nicely with this
with the with the geometrical intuitions
that one has in in sort of in the
geometrization of quantum mechanics
and that at least in in certain cases
where the uh
essentially in cases where the
multi-system obeys a strict
uh sort of what's called a modularity
property uh which is kind of a weakened
version of a distributivity property
that in fact we can prove that the the
combinatorial structure of the
multi-evolution graph
limits to the to the subspace structure
of a projective hilbert space as one
would study in ordinary quantum
mechanics
so i want to kind of walk you through
that derivation today but before i do
that i'm just going to quickly finish
off saying something that i was going to
say yesterday but i didn't really feel
like it
um which was uh so the you remember when
we when we did the derivation of srn gr
we we started with this very very kind
of naive toy case where we considered
the embedding of the causal network
into some lattice which we said you know
you could define a naive multi way as a
naive minkowski norm on
and we use that to derive at least in
the kind of one plus one dimensional
case with a grid-like causal network
we use that to derive certain features
of the lorenz transform i think as a
kind of intuition builder it's useful to
do the same thing here
so if we if we now consider taking the
multi-way evolution graph
and embedding it in in the lattice in
exactly the same way but now whether
where the coordinates
are those of time as in the causal
network case but now
rather than being a spatial coordinate
system x we instead have a branchial
coordinate system
y which is which is sort of the natural
quadratization not on the on the spatial
hypograph
but on the individual branchial graphs
and then we can
so then we can define a norm that's much
like the the naive minkowski normally
defined before which i'm going to
provisionally call
the the multi-way norm which again
allows us to separate
uh which allows us to classify states in
the system as being time-like
states if the norm is negative
branch-like states if the norm is
positive
and entanglement-like which are which
i'm going to use i'm going to use that
terminology in a slightly suggestive way
as the analog of the light-like
separation or light-like states or
light-like events
that that you'd see in an ordinary
space-time causal network um
the the essential intuition behind that
being as we'll see in a little bit
that uh sort of the the the prop that
whereas
in ordinary spacetime one defines the
conformal structure in terms of light
cones
uh here we define the conformal
structure of our multi-wave evolution
graph in terms of entanglement cones
cones that effectively state
uh which which micro states of the
universe have had time to get entangled
with which are the microstates
and so then the boundary of that cone is
is what we
it is the thing that defines the
entanglement like separations in the
multi-wave evolution graph but as i say
we'll make that correspondence a bit
more formal in a minute
so then if you given a pair of states
you can then you can then sort them out
into into whether they're they're
time-like separated branch like
separated or entanglement like separated
just like we did in the space-time case
based on uh you know based on the value
of the multi-way norm of the difference
between
between their two coordinates so
essentially what that's allowing us to
say is that you know if we see
uh a aaa and aba b and we know that
these these are time like separated
states
uh aba and aab here would be branch like
separated states
and you know sort of aa and aab would be
uh would be
entanglement wise separated states and
so this is this is obviously a very
simple kind of minkowski-like grid-like
multi-wave evolution graph for some very
simple string substitution
system and i'm showing it in its kind of
default foliation which you can think of
as being
like the multi-way analog of the
cosmological rest frame
that we considered in in the space-time
case and
um okay i have a little note here but
but uh as i say i'll i'll
explain this correspondence in a bit
more detail later but the reason why
we're able to say that that it makes
sense to say you know
that if if a pair of states are uh are
entanglement wise separated the reason
it makes sense to say that they
are entangled in some sense is that uh
even though they don't they may not
share a causal edge in actual space-time
they may not appear to be causally
related in space-time
but they can still share causal edges
with respect to the multi-way causal
network
so they can be they can be connected
with branch-like separated causal
ledgers even if they aren't separated
with space-like separated causal ledgers
uh so even if they aren't connected with
space like separated causal lectures
um and so in effect what you end up with
is the situation where two microstates
even if they're not spatially local
they can still be they can still be
correlated by virtue of the fact that
they have some common ancestry in the
multi-evolution graph
and so it's and then as we mentioned
yesterday it's really it's the branch
geographs that characterize the ancestry
distance between the micro states that
exist in the multi-evolution graph
so essentially this is why we've been
saying sort of
so far that that in effect it's the it's
the branchial graphs that designate the
patterns of entanglements between
elementary eigenstates
okay so then for this particular
foliation of the multi-evolution graph
this is the sequence of branchial graphs
that one would see this is the
particular sequence of
of of eigenstates the one we'd see as
being as being in linear superposition
um and so then if we if we had if we
considered instead an observer
with a corresponding to a different
foliation they would see a different
time-ordered sequence of
of superpositions between those
eigenstates um
and therefore if they attempted to
perform a measurement their measure
their completion procedure would be
different they would be
attempting to impose equivalences
between a different collection of
microstates and so the
the odds the observation of the eigen
state that gets collapsed
that their measurement collapses the
system down to would be different
you know the eigen states as seen but
for for observers performing
different measurement operations with
respect to different foliations will in
general be different
so we can see that explicitly if we if
we instead consider taking this this
sort of rest frame
foliation and boosting it like like like
some kind of lorentz boost but instead
of being some you know physical
instead of corresponding to something
concrete like physical motion in space
this is much something much more
abstract this is sort of related to
motion and branchial space
which corresponds to some parameterized
change of observer it's some
parameterized change
in the sequence of measurement
operations that the the person observing
the system is choosing to do
and so they see they're seeing a
different sequence of linear
superpositions and hence they're
performing
when they actually come to perform a
completion procedure that they they will
end up seeing different results
so in this case this is the branchial
graph as this is the sequence of
branchial graphs i've seen by this
observer in the boosted frame
so whereas before um we we saw that all
of the branchial graphs were connected
in this boosted frame the branchial
graphs are disconnected they have
disconnected components
so what that's indicating is with
respect to this this observers
in this observer's attempts to make
sense of what they see in the multi-wave
evolution graph
they see they see states as being
unentangled which the previous observer
in the rest frame
would have seen as being entangled
okay so then in exactly the same way as
we defined a conformal structure for
for sort of the larency and manifold in
the case of a causal network we can
define an entanglement structure on the
multi-evolution graph and entanglement
structure on branch shield space
so we can introduce concepts like
evolutionary precedence which is the
analog of chronological precedence in
space time
and we can introduce concepts like
entanglement wise precedence which would
be the analog of causal precedence
in space-time and then so so then given
given a particular microstate in the
multi-revolution graph we can examine
its its evolutionary future its
evolutionary past
and also its entanglement wise future
and its entanglement wise past
which uh which just as in the space-time
case correspond to the strict
interior of a light cone and the
interior plus boundary of a light cone
respectively except in this case of
course
it's not a light cone it's an
entanglement cone it's an illustration
of which which quantum states have had
an opportunity to become entangled
uh and which you know which states were
sufficiently far away in branchial space
that they cannot yet be entangled and
we'll come on to it
in uh in the in the sort of in the next
uh
section that i kind of want to walk you
through i'm going to explain exactly why
we think there's a there's a sort of
maximum rate of entanglement
why entanglements propagate in branchial
space at some finite speed
and why that connects with things we we
actually know of in sort of ordinary
experimental quantum mechanics
okay so this is yeah it's an
entanglement future entanglement past
evolutionary future and evolutionary
past
these are the you know the the
corresponding ideas of
of causal future cause of past uh
chronological feature and chronological
past respectively
we you know we don't just have to define
them for individual states we can define
them actually
for surfaces for for collections of such
states and so then the branch like hyper
so this this allows us to intuit
the branch like hypersurfaces are like
the space like hypersurfaces they're
like the cauchy surfaces that we defined
with respect to the causal network
and so then the the property that the
multi-wave evolution graph can be
foliated in this way
that it doesn't have close time-like
curves and it doesn't have kind of
degenerate
uh branchial branch evolutionary
connections between branch like
separated states
which is which is the analog of global
hyperbolicity in in the space time case
uh is essentially saying that it is
possible to set up a well-posed koshi
problem
uh in in the context of one of these
multi-evolution graphs if we take a
continuum limit
and that that ability to set up a
well-posted kosher problem
is what allows us to say that we can
define an invariant measure and that
in turn is related to the unitary of
evolution and again
we'll we'll see that's in just a little
bit okay so then
uh like much like in the causal network
then the the foliation of the multi-wave
evolution graph can be parameterized by
a local gauge choice in branchial space
except this time we're not we're not
specifying it in terms of a lapse and a
shift we're specifying
in terms of a lapse and a branchial
shift um
so but in all other respects you know
the combinatorics is the same so the
specification of the foliation is the
same
and so then the branch like
hypersurfaces are the level sets of the
universal time function that we set up
uh in the process of do of constructing
this uh
in the process of constructing a a
function t or the the sort of maps
uh states in the multi-wave evolution
graph onto onto integers corresponding
to the to their branch like hypersurface
so then uh we can think of an observer
before i had the slightly hand wavy
definition of an observer as being you
know some some macroscopic objects in
the ma
in the multi-evolution graph who
perceives the definite evolution history
now we can actually give a much more
precise definition they are a
time-ordered sequence
of equivalence classes between
microstates and and that time-ordered
sequence is parametrized by this
universal time function
okay so you remember in deriving special
relativity and general relativity and
making connections to lorentz symmetry
and local around symmetry
we we introduced this this notion of
causal invariance which which allowed us
to guarantee that independence of the
choice of foliation
the combinatorial structure was always
the same um
and we related this to the concept of
global confluence
there's an analogous sort of property
that we can consider here a property
that we call multi-way invariants
which is the statement of the
combinatorial structure of the multi-way
evolution graph
is invariant under the choice of
foliation that's something that's that's
a bit less well developed in in
you know with respect to mathematical
logic it's related to the property of
complete ability in internally writing
systems
so um you can have a terminal writing
system that is not globally confluent
but is nevertheless completable in the
sense that you could
perform a kinetics completion procedure
obtain a globally confident
rewrite system which has the same
deductive closure and so that's a weaker
condition than global confluence but but
it's still you know it's still a
stronger condition than nothing
and that's a you know effectively
multi-way invariance is the analog of
that
we're saying we're not saying that the
system is causing them variant but we're
saying that it's possible to set up
a foliation of the multi-wave evolution
graph into these branch-like
hypersurfaces
which the observer could then complete
in such a way as as to obtain a causal
invariant
evolution history okay so
we saw before sort of analogs of what
you might call inertial uh reference
frames of
inertial quantum observation frames uh
but you know just like in the space-time
case there's nothing to prevent you from
having the analog of gravitational field
configurations
you can construct effectively
arbitrarily wild uh
foliations of the multi-wave evolution
graph and so this is arguably
you know more like what an actual
quantum observation frame would look
like
in the non-inertial case okay
but um there's more to life than just
the multi-evolution graph you also have
to consider not just the
the individual states but the causal
relations between the events that
separate those states
so uh all of the structures that we've
considered so far
from the the space-time causal network
to the multi-evolution graph
can really be considered to be kind of
coarse-grained or fine-grained
approximations to this much more
fundamental object which is the
multi-way
causal graph so the multi-way causal
graph is the structure
that contains information not just about
the multi-way evolution but also about
causal connections
so if we construct a multi-way evolution
causal graph here
uh where all of the the sort of the blue
nodes correspond to the global states
yellow nodes correspond to the events uh
orange edges correspond to to the causal
relations
gray edges correspond to the evolution
edges then what we're saying is we can
we can take this evolution causal graph
and we can we can
essentially factorize it into a
multi-way evolution graph on the left
shown on the left here and a and a total
multi-way causal graph which we show on
the right
and actually you know in the same way as
it's possible to reconstruct the spatial
hypograph from the information in the
causal network
it's also possible always to reconstruct
the multi-way evolution graph from the
uh from the multi-way causal graph
so multi-way causal graphs are a
slightly uh sort of
complicated object because they contain
the causal relations not just from
space-time not just on single evolution
branches
but between different evolution branches
and so
even though this is a relatively simple
example this is more like what they look
what they appear to sort of look like in
practice uh but nevertheless it's still
possible to perform these factorizations
even if the multi-evolution graph
is sort of arbitrarily complex but
here's the point um in the multi way in
the two types of fundamental types of
networks that we've kind of constructed
coordinations of so far from the causal
network
and the multi-way evolution graph uh
there are only two types of separations
that one has to consider in the causal
network there's time like separation and
space like separation
and in the multi-way evolution graph
there's time like separation and
branch-like separation
but the point is that the multi-way
causal graph has all three types
there's time-like space-like and
branch-like separations and they're all
distinct they all have to whatever norm
you define on that space
has to effectively distinguish between
those three so
just like in space time when we have to
you know what one has to consider
the the timeline and space like
separations as having different signs
with respect to the standard space time
metric
we have to do the same thing here so uh
you know the
the kind of the the hand wavy way of
saying this would be
we need to have three independent
numerical directions in order to make a
an effective distinction between the
space like separations time like
separations and branch-like separations
now of course we already used
positive integers or positive numbers
for the for the space like separations
and negative numbers for the time-like
separations
so without loss of generality generality
we can use imaginary numbers for the
branch-like separations
and so then the natural metric that's
induced on
on the multi-way causal network is is
one in which which values are complex
rather than real
um and i'm going to give a more uh
rigorous sort of
uh explanation of why why we can do that
why we know and why it's actually
necessary to do that
now it's related to this thing called
the called sylvester's law of inertia
for quadratic forms
and so uh what it is essentially saying
is that
um the the the number of subs
one one has to have a distinct sign of
eigenvalue in the metric tensor
uh for for every distinct type for every
distinct subspace that
every type of subspace that exists
within your space so every distinct
every subspace that you want to keep
distinct uh has to has to be has to
correspond to a quadratic form with an
end with an eigenvalue that has an
independent sign from the other
from the other eigenvalues and so this
is why in the space-time case if you
want to be able to separate timeline and
space like separations you need to have
two signs
and it's why now in in the in the kind
of in the quantum
situation we need to have at least three
signs
um it's actually okay it's it's the the
this particular statement is is just for
real quadratic forms
there's an extension for quadratic forms
defined over arbitrary uh sort of uh
over arbitrary complex hilbert spaces
and things like that
um okay so
one immediate issue though is that we we
now have a kind of
we have an over-determined system if you
like because uh in the space-time case
when we just introduce positive and
negative numbers that's sufficient to
set that's sufficient to separate
space-like and time-like uh distances
and and it's and it kind of gives you no
more than you need but if we also
introduce complex numbers
then even if we use positive imaginary
numbers for the branch like separations
we also have negative imaginary numbers
which now have no c no direct
correspondence with respect to the space
so in other words because we're trying
to separate we're trying to keep a an
odd number of linear subspaces distinct
there is one additional degree of
freedom that we've introduced a
redundant degree of freedom that's been
introduced
by introducing a metric tensor that has
four independent uh
signs of eigenvalues so
in order to be able to get rid of that
uh that redundant degree of freedom what
we're saying is that we have to define
an equivalence class
between a a large collection of states
in the multi-evolution graph
and so that's what's actually that's the
reason uh loosely speaking that's the
reason why we obtain a projective
hilbert space as opposed to a regular
hilbert space the projectivity
the invariance of the structure of the
metric under projective transformations
is is exactly the thing that allows us
to get rid of the additional redundant
degree of freedom that was introduced
by by switching to cut to a complex norm
okay so uh this is not particularly
interesting this is kind of just
bookkeeping you know
if we now go to if we if we consider an
embedding in this in this
three-dimensional thing that this
or this this object which has three
independent components
this multi-wave minkowski lattice then
uh we can define a norm with respect to
that
uh the natural norm is complexified and
so now we have notions of time-like
light-like entanglement like space-like
and branch-like separations which you
might you might immediately see
are not necessarily mutually exclusive
in particular space-like separations are
sort of a special case of branch-like
separations
and light-like separations are a special
case of entanglement-like separations
and so on
and that as we'll see in a second
actually has implications for things
like the wave particle duality
so um what that's really saying is
if if the the if if space like
separation is just a special case of
branch-like separation
then what you're saying is that your
foliations
different foliations of the multi-wave
causal network will see
different pairs of states as being
either space-like separated or
branch-like separated that would be
something that is observer dependent
so to put that another way if you see a
collection of gd6 propagating the
multi-way causal network
how do you interpret that collection of
gd6 we've discussed in the relativistic
case that we can think of
a bundle of gd6 propagating in a causal
network
as being like the trajectories of a
collection of test particles that we use
to kind of
to determine the curvature of the space
and we also discussed how the
sort of a bundle of gd6 propagating in
the multi-way evolution graph
is something like a wave packet in
quantum mechanics because it's you know
each if each state is an eigen state and
so and so
a collection of eigen states that lie on
a branch like hypersurface corresponds
to a linear superposition
then the propagation of a geodesic
bundle is the propagation of a linear
superpo
is the time evolution of a linear
superposition of of those eigenstates
it's effectively a wave packet or a
polarization ellipsoid if you want to be
a bit more sort of mathematically fancy
so this statement that
uh the multi-way minkowski norm doesn't
allow you to globally separate space
like and branch like separation that
there isn't mutual exclusivity here
uh corresponds to the statement that for
some for observers in certain reference
frames for observers with certain
foliations of the multivariate causal
network a bundle of gd6 can either
appear to be purely space like separated
or purely branch like separated or a
collection of both and if they appear
purely space-like separated they will
appear to be a trajectory of test
particles
of some cloud of test particles if
they're purely branch-like separated
they will appear to be the
the trajectory of a wave packet and if
they're a mixture of the two
they'll seem to be somewhere in between
so effectively weight the
the the nature of wave particle duality
that the fact that uh
different different quantum observation
frames will will uh sort of
will perceive geodesic bundles as being
particle-like or wave-like
uh follows just sort of immediately from
the fact that there is not the
from the fact that there is a lack of
mutual exclusivity in
in the separation of states in the in
the multi-way with respect to this
naive uh multi-way minkowski norm but
just like we did in
relativity i now want to kind of take
you through how you can go about
deriving something that's a bit more
realistic that doesn't require this sort
of uh
ill-defined procedure of doing a layered
digraph embedding into into this lattice
so that's really what i what i want to
cover today
okay but to do that what we need to do
is define a sort of limiting geometry
and that was
relatively easy to do in the case of the
causal network we can kind of see how
that limits to something that that's
uh that that has the same conformal
structure as the royalty and manifold
but for these branchial graphs which
appear to be sort of exponential which
appears
so the the the nice thing about the
causal network is that in the cases
we're interested in it it does limit to
something that's
sort of finite dimensional with these
branchial graphs in general
they seem to grow exponentially so so in
other words they don't seem to limit to
anything that has a nice kind of fixed
finite dimension
which is which is immediately a problem
because it means that the same
techniques that we
uh that we applied in the causal network
case we actually have to adapt to deal
with this kind of exponential
dimensional case of the branchial graph
because of course
at each layer of the uh
hang on wait can you guys see this
can you guys see my lecture slides or am
i sharing the wrong thing
so you can see this thing called the
limits of bronchial space yeah we can
see it
okay cool sorry zoom was just completely
i had some yellow box appearing that i
wasn't sharing the right thing
but okay fair enough thanks um okay
so we're going to have to adopt we're
going to we have to adapt the techniques
somehow in order to make this this
analysis work
um all right but even in these cases we
can see that we're getting something
that does appear to have a limiting
geometry
so uh you know for we were considering
before branch or graphs for just
elementary string substitution systems
in the hypergraph cases you get branch
or graphs that have more realistic
geometries
uh and and so one immediate question we
can ask is what is the sort of natural
metric we define on a space like this
if it does indeed correspond to to a a
a well-posed geometrical space in in the
limiting case
well in the purely discrete case even
before we take a continuum limit
we can define a notion of a metric
because um we we kind of we
we know what it means for two states to
be separated by a certain distance in
the branch of graph
what what it means is if they're
separated by a distance of n if they're
separated by n branchial
edges what it means is that the ancestor
distance the ancestry distance between
those microstates
is is n with respect to the multi-wave
evolution graph so in other words you
would have to go back up n levels in the
multi-evolution graph before you found a
common ancestor
if if two states are totally
disconnected in the virtual graph that's
an indication they have no common
ancestry
so uh we can formalize that in terms of
algorithmic information theory
so um some of you may have encountered
this concept of kamalgarh complexity the
idea of quantifying the complexity of an
object
in terms of the length of the shortest
program or not the number of bits
contained in the shortest program that
would be required to generate that
object
you can generalize that notion to obtain
this this concept of a legend distance
or an edit distance
uh and the kind of the most complete
generalization is this thing called an
information distance
where the idea is if you have two
arbitrary states two arbitrary objects
uh you can ask what what is that what is
their what is the information distance
what is their distance with respect to
algorithmic information theory
and then the idea is it's it's a measure
of the distance
in terms of uh what is the length of the
shortest program
what is the commoner of complexity of
the uh that would be that would be
required for you to transform
uh one of those objects into the other
object so you have you have some uh
you you fix some universal turing
machine you fix some universal
programming language
and then you ask uh you know if we take
uh
if those two objects are input states
for that for that universal turing
machine
what is what is the minimum of the uh
what is the minimum length of the
program that
would be required either to reduce x to
y or to reduce y to x
and well in some form
uh the natural metric that's defined on
one of these branchial graphs is an
information distance right because
uh if you think of the multi-evolution
graph as performing a computation as we
discussed yesterday
then what we're asking is what is the
length of the shortest program what is
the length of the shortest rewrite
sequence
that allows you to write it yes yeah
okay
i think your swipes
hello sorry
what should we be seeing uh you you
should be seeing
something related to information
distance we
see an a multi-way main concept yeah
okay yeah yeah right that's what i was
checking okay so
so this is wrong let me
okay that's what i was talking about can
you see this now
yes yes yeah okay perfect information
space now okay got it yes yeah okay
sorry about that yeah
i okay zooms complaints at me was
correct
um okay yes so that may have seemed a
little bit obscure so let me just
quickly let me quickly recap that so i
was
what i was trying to show you was this
this kind of thing here which appears to
have a nice limiting geometry
um and i'm asking you know what what is
what is the obvious choice of metric for
that
for a space like that and so the the
point i was i was making
was that uh in in the discrete case the
natural metric is this thing called the
information metric or the information
distance
uh because what you're really asking is
what is the what is the minimum length
of the rewrite sequence you would need
to apply to derive states x and y from
some common ancestor state
so the ancestry distance in the
multi-evolution graph is really a form
of an information distance metric
um that was the main main point i was
trying to to make and so you can think
about this
as being a little bit like an edit
distance on strings or an edit distance
on hypergraphs
but it's really it's it's uh it's it's a
way of quantifying in terms of
algorithmic information theory
uh the the the concept of of an ancestry
distance
in something like a multi-wave system
so like i say it's it's a it's a natural
extension of the concept of comograph
complexity so if we introduce this
notation
k uh sort of x x bar y
to mean the camograph complexity of uh
if you have a program that accepts input
y
uh what you know what what what what is
the camograph complexity of the program
that
accepts input y and results in in object
x
uh we can denote that by by saying k x
bar y
in which case we can express the
identity uh the the information
uh distance metric uh directly in terms
of that karmagram in terms of a maximum
of the komogorov distances
or the camographer complexity measures
and it's not too difficult to prove that
the information distance metric does
indeed satisfy the actions of a metric
space
except that the metric inequalities have
some some term that's on the order of
the logarithm
of the maximum commodore of complexity
and that's essential so that's
essentially what you're doing is you're
introducing some additive constant
that's related to the translation
complexity
uh because there was some arbitrarity in
which which choice of universal turing
machine you you made
in in defining the information distance
but if you ignore that arbitrarity
everything else you get is essentially a
bona fide metric it satisfies the
accidents of a metric space
so at least in the discrete case we kind
of we know what that we know what the
the natural metric on branchial space
spaces so what happens when we go to a
continuum
well let's try and let's try kind of uh
semi-naively to adapt to the techniques
we developed in the general release of
the state case
um what we did before as you remember
is we tried to take a bunch of these
concepts from from romanian geometry
and and extend them to arbitrary metric
measure spaces by essentially taking the
concept of a volume measure in a
romanian manifold
and generalizing to the generalizing it
to the concept of a probability measure
in some metric space
so we're going to do the same thing um
and so some of you will know that
there's there's a
there are we introduced before this
notion of stein distance a
transportation distance which is a kind
of measure theoretic way
of quantifying distances between
probability measures
but there's an alternative way of
quantifying the same idea um
which is what's called an information
distance and the canonical one there is
what's called the fishermetric
and so um there's a really interesting
kind of collection of interplays between
fissure information distance and
rasherstein transportation distance
there are some
some situations in which the fischer
metric or the fischer rail metric uh
for certain kind of kind of statistical
manifolds is is directly proportional to
the fascist line distance and that that
gives you some
um the sort of the the situations in
which they're they they can be
considered
uh equivalent up to some multiplicative
constant other other situations where
that statistical manifold has some nice
homogeneity property but um the point is
that they're two independent ways of
quantifying distances
uh with respect to a statistical
manifold in other words with respect to
a manifold
in which every point is treated as some
probability measure
um so whereas the vascular strength you
know the intuition for the vaccine
metric
is that it's it's it's some it's some uh
transportation distance where you're
disassembling measures in one place and
transporting them to
transporting those measures to another
place and you're measuring the amount of
work done in doing that transportation
the fischer information metric is is
more like a
uh it's more like the algorithmic
complexity measure it
i mean it's related to this concept of
information geometry called the callback
label
divergence which is which is a which is
precisely a way of measuring discrepancy
between probability measures with
respect to some uh to some
common probability space and it has nice
smoothness properties that in fact
are unsatisfied in general by things
like the vacherstein metric
okay so um
we can although it's it's sort of it's
conventional to
write the physiometric tensor in this
sort of integral form we can also write
it purely in a matrix form
that's nice because it allows us to make
explicitly the correspondence
between the the continuum fissure
information metric and the discrete
information metric that we defined
earlier
because if we if we rewrite it if we
rewrite the integral
form as an explicit matrix form then we
see it's actually
it's it's a metric that's defined with
respect to the second derivative
of an entropy of a self-information
contribution that is exactly the entropy
that one would see in ordinary
information theory it's it's
you know it's exactly the shannon
entropy
um and so you know as i mentioned here
the you know the implication of that
is that if as long as your probability
distributions are all computable
then the then the expectation value of
the common growth complexity is exactly
the shannon entropy
and so we can make this nice
correspondence between this this
continuous concept
which is the fischer distance and this
this otherwise discrete concept
which is the chromograph complexity and
the resultant information distance
so this gives us a sort of a way of
saying that if there exists a continuum
limit
of these brancheal graphs then the
natural distance metric that was the
information distance
in the discrete case will become the
fischer distance in the continuous case
okay so again as a kind of as a quick
intuition pump
we can we can think you know this is an
example of a geometry that's clearly
higher dimensional it's clearly not
something we can easily represent in
three dimensions
that exists uh that's constructed uh by
by evolving a multi-wave evolution
system for an elementary string
substitution rule
so what we're saying is if we do if we
perform essentially a surface
reconstruction of this
as some higher dimensional object we're
saying that the individual discrete
information distances that are
that are represented by the edges will
become uh something like a continuous
fischer information distance
okay there's a great i i just want to
show you this because they're kind of
cool to look at there's a great
diversity of kind of limiting geometries
even in the most elementary cases
so these are the these are the pures you
know string substitution one-dimensional
cases
and in fact these are even the simplest
possible string substitution rules that
just have single elements on the left
and even with this extremely restricted
class of rules you still see great
diversity of kind of limiting
higher dimensional geometries but
nevertheless
in every case because we have you know
because we know the underlying discrete
metric
we also know the we we also know the
kind of continuum approximation to that
metric
as the as as these branches graphs get
arbitrarily large that's the second typo
i've spotted in this
um i need to i need to do a better job
of typing these out anyway
okay what does any of this have to do
with quantum mechanics well
here's the exciting thing if we we've
already mentioned that actually
we you know the the the space we're
considering which is the you know
the space produced by the limits of the
multi-way causal network is one that
doesn't have a real norm but actually
has a complex norm
um and so you know one question you
might ask is if we have some complex
projective space which is what we've
essentially defined what is the natural
metric that exists on that space well
it turns out the most general natural
calor metric in other words the most
natural
metric that has compatible complex
structure imani and structure
and synthetic structure is this thing
called the fubini studio metric it's
it's the kind of canonical metric that
you would define
on you know on on a projective space
with a complex norm
um and and and it's the it's the thing
that allows projective hillbilly spaces
to to have non-trivial curvature
so with an ordinary helmet space of
course you know the the hilbert norm is
is
sufficiently boring that you can't have
any non-trivial geometry in an ordinary
hilbert space an ordinary hobbit space
doesn't have any any notion of curvature
sort of associated to it but if you
allow for a projective hilbert space you
can
because you can define a a generalized
romanian metric at kayla metric
which is the fubini study metric and and
so
the general form uh looks something like
this um
okay so it's hang on
zoom is doing something weird for me
okay hopefully that's still visible
again i keep getting flashing warning
messages i'm wondering what they mean
okay so this is the explicit form of the
fubini study metric
written in terms of in terms of some
hermitian form for the for the
underlying complex projective hilbert
space
um if we wanted to write it okay if we
can write it out even more explicitly in
terms of index notation we get something
like this
um and this is um
immediately compact we know that this is
immediately compatible with efficient
with the fischer information distance
because in fact if you take the uh if
you take the real part of the fubini
study metric it's equivalent
up to i think a factor of four uh it's
equivalent uh
to uh precisely to the fischer
information metric for the for this
complex projective hilbert space
and the reason why that's exciting is
because the fubini study metric is
exactly something that appears in the
geometry in the sort of standard
geometrization of quantum mechanics if
you want to consider states not with
respect to an ordinary hilbert space but
with respect to a to a complex
projective hilbert space
then uh the framini story studio metric
is the thing you know is the thing you
use there
and in fact it's what allows you to sort
of explain a lot of concepts like
quantum entanglement
and berry phase in terms of essentially
uh oddities in
in the in the metric distance as sort of
endowed by the public study just
for being studio metric so
uh in sort of things like quantum
information theory you might consider
the fubini study metric over something
like cp1 which would be the block sphere
in our case we're considering the fubini
study metric over cpn
for for a kind of arbitrarily large
value of n because we know that these
branchio graphs
uh you know limit to sort of arbitrarily
high dimensional objects
so um if we rewrite uh if we rewrite the
fubini study metric not in terms of this
sort of skew
permission form but in just explicitly
in terms of the bracket notation
then we can see it's equivalent to uh to
this thing called the borough's metric
or the borough's angle
which is one method of sort of
quantifying the distance between quantum
states in some hilbert space
um so it's kind of an alternative things
like the trace distance or the fidelity
distance
and the burst angle you can think of as
being a quantification of entanglement
distance
okay so that's immediately quite
exciting if we you know
we've been able to start from this
purely discrete structure which is the
information distance on the branchial
graph
and we've obtained something that at
least in the case where the branch of
graph limits to a complex projective
hilbert space
we we have we have an object that we
know in the quad you know
by analogy to ordinary sort of geometric
quantum mechanics is a quantification of
entanglement between microstates
and so this allows us to give a sort of
slightly more formal justification
to our previous statement that
entanglement is essentially a measure of
ancestry in the multi-wave evolution
graph and
therefore the branchial graphs are
really representing patterns of
entanglements between those microstates
and we should note here that this this
notion of projective projective symmetry
this idea that we can perform projective
rescalings of the branchial graph
without changing uh without changing the
structure of the norm that we
as i say is a symmetry we've had to
impose by the fact that our metric is
over determined um
this is analogous to the statement that
the the the the sort of the conformal
the
causal structure of a lorentzian
manifold is invariant under under
conformal rescaling except here instead
of
instead of uh being instead of saying
that the that we have some network
that's invariant under the action of a
conformal group
of we were actually saying that the the
resultant network is invariant
uh under the action of a projective
group
okay so uh if we stop considering the
toy case of the of the of the branchial
graphs for pure multi-wave evolution and
we instead consider
the the sort of the more more serious
case of
multi-way causal networks and their
limiting geometries we see something we
see
we get things that are even more
complicated but still nevertheless do
appear to have kind of well posed uh
sort of potentially infinite dimensional
geometries in the continuum limit and so
these are the things we're claiming
are limiting to projective hilbert
spaces and and say as long
as long as as long as they limit to a
space on which we can on which we can
define
a a a a a something like a hermitian
form over cpn
then we know that this this justifies
all of the previous claims about
about relationships between a sort of
branchial distance and an entanglement
distance
okay so one question you could ask is is
there any kind of precedence to this
notion of having a purely combinatorial
representation of a projective space it
seems like a slightly weird idea i mean
combinatorial representations of
of spaces like the rancid manifolds you
might be able to get your head around
because you can kind of just think of
them as being you know skeletonizations
that you would construct in causal set
theory or something
but you know with something like a
projective hilbert space or an infinite
dimensional projective hilbert space
you know is there any is there any
precedence for thinking about that
combinatorially
turns out there are a whole bunch uh one
of them is is this concept of a steiner
system that we investigated for a little
while before essentially discarding them
as being
largely irrelevant to this project but
they're still they're a cool structure
so i'll just talk about them for a
second
um so if you if you want to construct a
finite projective plane
uh a steiner system gives you a purely
combinatorial way of doing that
so it's a it's a collection of blocks of
a certain size and a collection of
points that that are contained within
those blocks
and so you can wrap you can represent a
sinus system as some graph
and okay if so um
right okay so then
if you consider something like the the
the funnel plane which is which is the
kind of
i think it's the simplest uh so which is
the simplest finite model of the of the
of a projective plane it's it's the
particular case where you have uh what
is it seven point seven lines
three points in every line three lines
through every point um and so it's it's
it
uh i think it's it's commonly denoted as
pg-22
so it's it's the projective geometry on
on on two comma two
and it can be represented by a steiner
triple system so a triple system where
where k is three and and equal to t plus
one
um and so this is a this is a
combinatorial way of representing
the kind of the incidence geometry of
the of the finite projective plane
uh at least in the simplest case
okay so one thing we considered is can
we think of these partial graphs as
being like
like like steiner systems can we think
of them as being like combinatorial uh
reconstructions of the projective plane
uh it turns out that's probably not the
case because
uh if you look at the growth rates in
something like a steiner system and you
look at the standard growth rates that
appear in branchiographs
they're quite radically different if you
look you know so here here's the growth
rate in these steiner systems simulated
by a sequence of hypergraphs
here are the growth rates as as seen in
an ordinary branchial graph
and they have they have radically
different structures now
the reason why they have radically
different structures we think is because
something like a steiner system for as a
representation of the finite projective
plane
is is what's called incidence geometry
so in other words where where every line
so okay every edge is is actually
it corresponds to a line in in the
projective plane
every every vertex corresponds to a
point and so where
so the the the steining system is
representing the incidences between
lines and points in in the projective
plane but there's an alternative notion
an alternative way to construct
combinatorial representations of
projective spaces
which is instead of being instance
geometric is pretty
is is what's what's commonly called a
continuous geometric uh this is a so
continuous geometry is a field of study
that was developed i think like berkel
and von neumann
quite a long time ago back in i suspect
the 1930s
where instead of representing the the
relative uh incidences of things like
lines and points
you're instead representing the the
relative containments of linear
subspaces
so the idea is if you consider something
like a hilbert space
um what von neumann and burkhoff
realized was that you can relax the
standard axioms for for a complex
hilbert space
by just describing it in terms of what
is that what is the containment
structure of the linear subspaces
so you can construct a partial order
that is essentially saying for a given
linear subspace
which other linear subspaces is it
contained within and which of which
linear subspaces are contained within it
and given that partial order you can
construct the hassa diagram for it like
we do in
causal networks and you end up with with
essentially with a directed acyclic
graph
that is representing the the order
theoretic structure of
of that particular uh that particular
hilbert space and
the nice thing about incidents sorry the
nice thing about about sort of
containing
containment geometry or continuous
geometry is that unlike incidence
geometry
it generalizes not from from ordinary
hilbert spaces to projective hilbert
spaces
in a very natural way whereas uh
something like instance geometry can
really only deal with with things like
finite projective planes
okay so if we consider if we take
something like a lattice so in other
words
if we take some we take a post set
wherever you know
every pair has a unique uh supreme a
unique infumum
um then we can define a relaxation of
the distributivity condition which we'll
call modularity
and then uh so and then modularity is is
so modularity is a property that can be
that can be exhibited by a particular
pair of elements in that post set
and then the overall lattice can be
called modular if every pair of
of elements in that with in that post
set is
is itself modular so um
here's an example of a modular lattice
um
essentially the the intuition for what's
going on with respect to modulators
in terms of what we've already
encountered in in multi-wave evolution
graphs
is that a a modular pair a a pair of
elements that satisfies uh
the satisfies the modularity condition
is a resolvent
a one-step resolvent branch pair in the
multi-evolution graph so we can tell
that this lattice this particular
lattice is a modular lattice because we
because we can see for every every place
where there's a bifurcation in the
hustle diagram for that post set
there is immediate one-step
reconvergence and so the way that this
is stated in
in terms of ordinary sort of order
theory and lattice theory is that this
is a
this is a post set for which the diamond
isomorphism theorem holds so
so if if we take this if we take this
lattice we can think of a generalization
of the standard second isomorphism
theorem from from universal algebra
uh because the uh essentially we're
allowed to do that because the
the modular lattice can be considered a
variety with respect to some
universal algebra it's it's the it's the
algebraic structure that says
that satisfies a particular set of
relations in a universal algebra
um and so then then the second
isomorphism theorem becomes the
statement of the diamond isomorphism
theorem
which is essentially the statement that
the modular pairs are
that all of the modular pairs are
reconvergent
uh okay here's a slightly more formal
way of saying that um
so it's here's a
but here's a more explicit example so so
here you can see this is a case where
we we know because you know if
if the common ancestor is is the meat of
the two elements a and b
and the common resolvant is the join
then we're effectively saying
anytime there is a common ancestor
within a single step there is also a
common resolvent within a single step
that's that's what the statement of
modularity is giving you and then the
diamond isomorphism theorem gives you a
sufficient condition and a necessary
condition
for the violation of that modularity
which is you know which in our case
would correspond to the situation
where you have a where you have a branch
pair that does not resolve in a single
step
so here's an example of that occurring
here with respect to this poset
okay so
uh so therefore we know that if if the
if the underlying multi-wave evolution
graph limits to something that that
becomes a modular lattice then we know
that's a sufficient condition for
guaranteeing causal and variants because
of it if bro
one-step branch pair convergence is
sufficient is a sufficient condition for
global confidence
and therefore for for for causal
invariants
okay so then continuous geometry that
this this uh alternative accidentization
of sort of projective hilbert's base
geometry that von neumann developed
considers modular lattices that are
complete uh continuous
uh and complementary and so so in other
words all subsets
not only does every pair of elements
possess a joint and meet but all subsets
of the lattices
possess a join and meet because
effectively if you have not just a
single then
a pair of linear subspaces but an
arbitrary collection of linear subspaces
they should also have a common
subspace that contains them and a common
subspace that they contain
uh complementary complementarity states
that effectively you can negate
with the exception of the minimal and
maximal lattice elements it's possible
to negate any lattice element
by taking its complement that you know
that's the notion that for any linear
subspace you can take its complementary
space
uh then there's then there's the
continuity property that essentially
says the joint and meat operations are
associative um
you know which is of course trivially
true in the in the case of projective
hillbilly spaces if you know if
a contains b and b contains c then we
know a a contains c so we have
transitivity
and b but in particular we also have
that if the
overall space in which a contains b
itself contains c that's equivalent to
saying that the
the the the the subspace a
contains the overall space in which uh
subspaces b and c contain each other
um and irreducibility which is the
statement that there are only two
uh elements that possess unique
complements which are the the minimal
element and the maximal element and the
lattice respectively
so as long as you have a lattice a
modular lattice that satisfies all four
of those conditions
you can you can treat that as being the
skeletonized version of some projective
hilbert space
so in other words what that's doing is
telling us that that
our our idea that if we have a multi-way
evolution graph that has
that is capable of achieving one-step
causal and variance for instance by
completion procedure
that the the the the axioms of
continuous geometry are the thing that
justify us
treating the multi-evolution graph as
being the post set
that represents the containment
structure of some projective hilbert
space
okay so if that's if all of that is true
uh what does that tell us about actual
quantum mechanics i'm aware i don't have
a huge amount of time left and i'm also
uh
i'm running a bit i'm kind of running
out of steam in my own
uh energy levels but okay we can make it
through to the end i'm sure
so um what does that actually
entail so in in the same way as the
structure of the causal network placed
constrain you know the geometry the
limiting geometry of the causal network
placed constraints
on what was going to happen uh in terms
of the the propagation of geodesic
bundles in the causal network
in exactly the same way the limiting
geometry of the multi-way evolution
graph
is going to place certain constraints on
the evolutions of wave packets on the
evolutions of polarization ellipsoids
through through the multi-wave system
and so then you know our hypothesis
would be
that instead of the einstein hilbert
action we're going to get something like
a path integral
and so how would something like that
that work well
if you consider the the individual wave
packets as being transformations from a
co-set of pure states which are like the
goldstone modes
um which are the which are essentially
the the um
those are the the the deformations of
the wave packet
but you can also consider rotations of
the wave packet which are uh
transformations from the isotropy group
the pure state isotropy group
which corresponds to the higgs modes
then that gives us a geometrization it
gives us a way of considering
considering the motion of that of that
particular bundle of gd6
so then if each individual pure state is
a ray in the projective hilbert space
which we kind of which we now believe to
be true right
that corresponds to a single infinite
geodesic that is
through the multi-evolution graph that
that is the evolution of that particular
pure state
well now we can make a natural
coordinate choice by defining a chart
atlas a coordinate atlas
on on on the cp uh on the space cpn
minus one
and so then that allows us to write out
the fubini studio metric in a very
explicit form
and then if we if we want to incorporate
so so
obviously in the ordinary path integral
action uh the the
the only contribution is the one is the
contribution that appears as a
consequence of the of the magnitude
of of the of the individual quantum
amplitudes uh so that appears
as a consequence of the phase of the
individual quantum amplitudes and the
magnitudes are essentially ignored
um in the multi-evolution graph where
the the where the phase is essentially
the angle at which the gdc
is propagating and the and the magnitude
is the is the path
is the pathway to that particular
geodesic is the pathway to the
microstates that are obtained on that
gdc
we don't immediately have that have that
luxury so we have to make an explicit
separation between the two so we have to
impose a mild breaking of the projective
symmetry
which generalizes the fabrini study
metric a little bit and we obtain this
thing here
for some radius r that is the the that
is effectively the density sphere so so
if we think of each
of each ray each each uh each pure state
in this projective hilbert space as
being stereographically projected from
some from some analog of the arena
from some rhema sphere uh then then the
then the the uh
the the it's the the radius of that
rhema sphere is the thing that's
appearing as the
as the coefficient in in the in the
generalized variant of the fubini study
metric
so with with that coordinate chart
defined
what the conjecture that we therefore
make is that just like the einstein
curvature tensor which is the left hand
side of the einstein field equations is
the thing that's placing constraints on
the on the propagation of the geodesic
bundles
in the causal network uh we would make
the we would make the hypothesis that
this
gik quantity here on the left hand side
of this sort of generalized version of
the einstein equations
is what's placing constraints on the
propagation of geodesic bundles in the
multi-wave causal network in other words
it's what's placing
is what's placing constraints on the on
the deformations and rotations
of the polarization ellipsoid as it
moves uh through through this uh
projective hilbert space okay but in
defining a connection which is what we
did you know
by by defining this coordinate atlas we
have implicitly defined a gauge
potential
um and we don't really know exactly what
that means we don't know what what
concepts like local gauge invariants uh
correspond to with respect to these
buffer model systems we have a
conjecture but we're hoping that uh
well maybe graham might be able to
answer this fight uh by the completion
of his project
but so the the sort of the into the
current intuition that we're pursuing
with respect to what what something like
an intrinsic gauge potential would
actually mean
is a set of restrictions on possible
orientations of applications of rewrite
rules
so if you're if you're considering how
you parameterize possible updating
orders
uh we've already discussed how you
essentially have to consider the
maximally consistent
set of space-like separated updating
events so
then if you consider the actual
hypergraph as being like a fiber bundle
and with a way where each vertex is like
a fiber then each each hypograph which
is
each hyper edge which is defining a
possible orientation of an elementary
rewrite rule
um can be thought of as like a local
choice of coordinate system
why do i say that well it's because you
know it
depending on which orientation of the
rewrite rule we apply that will that
will place that will place certain
constraints it will place conditions on
which orientations of rewrite rules we
can apply
in other parts of the hypergraph so it's
as though by making that initial
initial coordination choice there is a
there is
there is essentially a set of
constraints that are propagating out in
some gauge field that are constraining
how how we can apply that rewrite rule
in other places around the network
so here's a simple example of that these
are you know this is a simple square
network
and we can see there are two possible
places in which we could apply this this
simple
replacement operation here but depending
on which of these two orientations we
choose
this will place certain constraints on
which other orientations of rules we can
apply
at future steps when we attempt to
evolve other parts of the hypergraph
so like i say the interpretation of that
is that
the hypergraph is treated as some base
space each vertex is treated as a fiber
each hyperedge is some local choice of
coordinate basis and then
essentially causal and variance becomes
a sufficient condition for for local
gauge and variant because causal and
variance
immediately implies that you know
independent of which rewrite order you
choose
you know the the hypergraphs you end up
up with are either either isomorphic
or are hypergraphs which have the same
underlying causal structure
um and so here if you have causal
invariance that means that it doesn't
matter what initial choice of coordinate
basis you
you make it doesn't matter what
constraints propagate out in the gauge
field
uh you know the hypergraphs you end up
with still have the same causal
structure
so cause the variance allows us to use a
sort of a discretized version of local
gauge invariants
at least assuming that this particular
interpretation of what it means to
define a gauge potential
uh is actually true
okay so i mentioned that in in in
performing this construction
we have we have made a separation
between the the notion of the the angle
of the geodesic which is the phase that
appears in the path integral formula
and the notion of the of the weighting
the path weighting which is the
which is the concept that appears in in
terms of magnitudes of quantum
amplitudes
uh with respect to measurement
procedures and so this is something that
uh you know of course we for notational
convenience we represent with a single
complex number
but it's worth noting that in the
multi-way evolution graph they are
treated as
essentially being independent quantities
where as far as we know there is there's
no situation we've yet encountered where
you essentially have to to accommodate
both uh both objects
within a single system of equations uh
essentially
all of the systems we've got all of the
connections to ordinary quantum
mechanics we've analyzed so far
have either been at the level of the
path integral where the phase is the
only thing that matters
or the level of measurement where the
magnitude is the only thing that matters
and i mean if people are if people know
of any kind of situations where both
magnitude and phase
you know where it's important to
consider both magnitude and phase
in a quantum amplitude as being on the
same level i'd be really interested to
hear about that because that's you know
that's that's a place where potentially
we might be able to make uh different
experimental predictions
from the experimental predictions made
by ordinary quantum mechanics
okay but just just quickly to wrap up in
terms of making experimental predictions
that are consistent with ordinary
quantum mechanics
two immediate things that follow from
from making this correspondence between
the space-time causal network and the
multi-way causal network and by implying
that
essentially quantum mechanics is some
generalized version of general
relativity
occurring with respect to the multi-wave
causal network and with respect to
branchial space
one of those is the the analog of the
finiteness of the speed of light so
you know obviously the the fact that the
causal network is not fully connected
that
it takes a sort of non-trivial number of
causal edges to traverse from one point
in space to another point in space
is the statement that c is finite and we
have the same thing in the multi-way
causal network the multi-causal network
is
maybe much more uh much more densely
connected than
the causal network so the the effective
speed of light much might be much higher
but it's still nevertheless finite it
limits to a finite value if we take some
continuum limit of the branch of
geometry
so does there exist an analogous notion
in quantum mechanics
that can be tested experimentally well
actually yes there does uh people
have sort of researched things related
to
quantum speed limits i think the the
earliest example of this is probably the
mandelstarm tam
bound that was proved back in 1945 that
gives effectively a time uncertainty
relation that bounds the effective speed
of evolution
uh as a consequence of energy
dissipation there's a more formal
version of the same idea which is the
margolis leviton theorem
and so the way that that works is if you
uh if you consider
the evolution of some initial state
capsi naught to some final state
kepsai t and you ask i i want capsi
naught and capsid to be to be
observationally distinguishable
is there some minimum time that's
imposed by the canonical computation
relations
uh is there some minimum value of t that
has to that has to have elapsed before
those two states become distinguishable
well if you if you take keps i know and
you expand it out in the energy eigen
basis
and you consider the you consider keps i
t to be a solution to the time dependent
schrodinger equation for some constant
energy
then you can compute the overlap you can
com you can project capsid naught onto
capsid
and consider its real part and then by t
by applying an elementary trigonometric
uh
inequality you can you can obtain an
inequality for for that real part
and so you can then determine up you can
determine a lower bound on the value of
t
in order for the in order for the
overlap of capsid naught and capsize t
to be non-zero
so as long as the as long as the average
energy is constant and itself
non-negative
then and the initial and final states
are are mutually orthogonal
then that imposes a minimum bound on the
evolution time which is the marginalized
leviton bound and you can see
immediately that it's proportional to h
bar
which is why uh before i justified i i i
made this sort of slightly mysterious
statement
in the previous talk about how the
maximum rate of entanglement is directly
related to hbar the the the effective
rate of information propagation and
hence the elementary branchial
edge length is is related to hbar and
that was that that was the sort of the
piece of magic that we introduced
in in claiming that the uh the
elementary separation distance with
respect to the
so the canonical communication relations
was ih bar now we can see why that's
actually true
it's the margolis leviton bound that
gives us the maximum rate of
entanglement that gives us the maximum
rate
uh the maximum rate at which quantum
microstates can become
uh can become statistically correlated
um and
it's the it's the structure of the
multi-way minkowski norm
it's it's the structure of the of this
metric that we've introduced on the
projective hilbert space in which branch
like separations are treated uh treated
as imaginary numbers that gives us the i
in front of the ih bar so the so
that this is one immediate consequence
of the geometry of the multi-evolution
graph that that we know is compatible
with within with known experiments in
ordinary quantum mechanics
there's also a more subtle thing which
is in the same way as you know
successively steepened foliations of the
multi-way causal network result in
something like relativistic time
dilation as we saw in in the case of
where we were treating lorentz
transformations what we would expect
what we'd expect to see is that if you
have an observer who exists in some
boosted foliation of the multi-wave
evolution graph
that their you know their perception of
time with respect to the quantum
evolution between microstates
would be slowed down by the same effect
because the geometries are the same in
other words
what we would expect to see is some
quantum mechanical analog some some
multi-way system analog
of relativistic time dilation uh so we
obviously that that's something we
directly observe when we when we
consider boosted foliations of the
multi-way system
so what you know how how can we make a
connection between this idea
and and again things that might be
experimentally testable in ordinary
quantum mechanics
well if we interpret the overlap between
capsid naught and it's its time-evolved
version as being some survival
probability
then we can ask after the system has
evolved to that future state kept psi t
um what what what what what would happen
if we take that time interval
the interval between naught and t and
you know considering it to be some unit
interval
if we just punctuate it by a sequence of
orthogonal projections of
instantaneous projections that we can
idealize as being like measurement
operations
well then if we just perform a timer if
we if we perform a power series
expansion in time
of of this part of the schrodinger
equation here then we can rewrite the
the
then up to second order we can write the
survival probability like this
uh in terms of this quantity uh delta h
delta h hat again we're assuming
constancy
uh of of the energy for the system so
then as i say if we if we punctuate this
unit time interval
uh by by a sequence of instantaneous
projections what's gonna happen
well essentially that corresponds to
taking the limit as n goes to infinity
of of this term here
which is which is clearly going to
converge to one because this second
order the s
the second order term converges to zero
much faster than the
than the first order term does and so in
the limit as n goes to infinity
this tells us the survival probability
that the probability of measuring capsid
naught and its time of old version
as being uh as being the same is going
to limit to one in other words
or to put in another way the overlap
between the initial state and the final
state becomes one
and so the initial state and the final
state become the same in the limit as we
take an infinite number of orthogonal uh
of instantaneous orthogonal projections
so what this is
implying is that the more measurement
operations we perform the slower the
unitary evolution this is this thing
called the turing paradox or the quantum
xena
paradox and it's not limited i i happen
to specify it in terms of instantaneous
projections
and in terms of sort of instantaneous
measurement operations it's a much more
general effect than that it actually
applies
in essentially any in any interaction
with the environment any kind of
interaction with a stochastic field
will result in in effectively the limit
of the of the survival probability
converging to one
and so so this is again a a a concept
that we directly see in ordinary quantum
mechanics this notion that as the
observer
moves to a boosted foliation as they
attempt to perform more and more
measurement operations
by by sampling a larger and larger
region of branchial space which is the
analog of motion
in in ordinary physical space uh you
know our formulation our purely
geometrical formulation of quantum
mechanics
in terms of geodesics and the multi-wave
evolution graph would imply that their
observation of the of the time evolution
would get slower and slower and and
again that that's an effect that we can
precisely reproduce
in the standard of hilbert space
formulation of quantum mechanics okay so
i'm aware that i've run out of time
um and so i there are some other things
that we may discuss later on in the week
if
we have time or something but that's
probably that's probably enough to be
getting on with for now
um i think we're supposed to now shift
into the group discussion session
which is not in uh this particular room
so i mean
i'm having to take any quick questions
before we run out of time here but
otherwise
we can we can shift to the group
discussion
thanks
i just have a quick do you have a
reference you recommend for
kind of just the continuous version of
the geometrization of
uh quantum mechanics uh yes okay yeah
sure
there are a bunch but the one that i'm
particularly fond of okay there's an
italian guy called leifler
who has developed a lot of these ideas
of of essentially reinterpreting quantum
mechanics purely in terms of fubini
study geometry
uh and so he has this notion um it's a
slightly hokey notion
um but the the the mathematics is sound
i'm just i'm not so convinced about the
physical interpretation of it
um which is this thing called super
relativity which is uh which is
essentially a very
very directly related concept to what
we're trying to do um just
formulated in a way that i don't
completely agree with um where
where where in the same way as you know
the
the the space metric tensor in in
ordinary romanian geometry is what
is what determines the geographic
trajectories in the continuum case
uh the the foubini studiometric tensor
is what determines the trajectories in
this in this projective hilbert case
um there so so lefleur has done a lot of
work on on the
on the purely continuous version of that
um
in terms of yeah as for references of
this this the discrete case
i'm much less confident that there
exists any i i at least certainly
haven't been able to find any but i can
send you the the
the preprints and papers of leiflow if
that's helpful
that'd be great thanks